on the afternoon of 20th november 1952
a small group of people milled around a
canyon
outside desert center california
led by the self-style professor george
adamski
the group came to this isolated spot
halfway between
palm springs and the arizona border to
photograph
flying saucers among them was
25 year old george hunt williamson
an ex-military man an amateur
archaeologist
61 year old professor adamski set up a
telescope
and waited for the alien craft to appear
and he wasn't disappointed he claimed
not only to see
various spacecraft but also to meet a
real
live venusian named orthot
only adamski witnessed the visitation
but his young helper williamson took
plaster casts
of desert footprints that revealed
cryptic symbols on the soles of his
shoes
adamski recounted the experience in his
book
flying saucers have landed and he became
a leading figure
in the so-called golden age of ufos
incidentally 1952 was also the year that
the air force started
its longest and most serious study of
the ufo phenomenon
project blue book the most interesting
and mysterious person at desert center
however was
george hunt williamson he was no
run-of-the-mill nut in a tinfoil hat
maybe the first thing to understand
about george hunt williamson
is that he was born in chicago under the
name of george
leonard williamson and during his
lifetime he would assume
various identities drafted into the u.s
army air corps in 1945
williamson was assigned to public
relations
and coincidentally or not air force pr
personnel later played prominent roles
in investigating and debunking
ufo sightings after leaving the military
williamson relocated to arizona to
attend the university of arizona
in pursuit of a graduate degree in
archaeology
that same year he also traveled to
lincoln county new mexico
about an hour west of roswell to work on
an archaeological dig
or so he claimed only two years earlier
roswell had been the site of probably
the first and most controversial
reported
ufo crash so was williamson hunting
for indian artifacts or something else
i should add that williamson was briefly
recalled to u.s military service in 1949
and received a second lieutenant's
commission
later he also received a commission in
the newly christened air force's
civilian auxiliary the civil air patrol
becoming a lieutenant colonel
williamson's academic studies came to a
halt in 1951
when he was expelled from the university
for unspecified reasons
in the meantime he picked up a wife
betty
who became his enthusiastic assistant
professor george adamski meanwhile
first arrived in southern california
during the 1920s
when a hoped-for movie career didn't pan
out he opted to form
a cult this was the royal order of tibet
also known as the
temple of scientific philosophy
really it was a thinly disguised rip-off
of an
older mystical school called the
theosophical society
that blended eastern and western
mysticism
and pioneered what we now call the new
age movement
adamski dispensed timeless wisdom for a
modest fee
but the real secret of a success was the
religious
exemption that the royal order of tibet
received to make
and serve wine at its gatherings after
all
these were america's prohibition years
repealed in december 1933 spelled doom
for adamski's booze dispensing temple of
scientific philosophy
so by 1940 he was flipping burgers at a
little roadside cafe
at the foot of mount palomar adamski had
no connection to the observatory there
but he tried hard to give the impression
that he did he set up a couple of
telescopes and gave lectures to gullible
tourists
when flying saucers became the rage
adamski started snapping photographs
of mysterious airborne objects
that attracted a small band of followers
including
george hunt williamson still i wonder if
it was
mere curiosity that brought williamson
to desert center
that day in 1952
maybe the army air corps veteran was
there on someone
else's orders to check out adamski and
his group
in any event williamson went on to
publish his own book
the saucer speak and its sequel other
tongues
other flesh around this time williamson
also showed up on the radar of fbi
director j edgar hoover
the fbi was concerned that some of the
alien visitors reported by ufo
enthusiasts
preached universal brotherhood and
nuclear disarmament
it raised suspicions that this flying
saucer business
might be an insidious commie plot
the fbi in investigating williamson
soon turned up evidence that he was
involved in smuggling antiquities
and maybe drugs out of mexico still
the feds never touched him and maybe
that's related to those
national security redactions in his file
not long afterward williamson gathered
up betty and headed off to peru
there calling himself brother philip he
claimed to represent a secret order
called the brotherhood
of the seven rays was this a genuine
spiritual quest
or more cover if running an esoteric
monastery in the andes
was what williamson was really up to it
proved difficult
in 1958 betty died of fever and
malnutrition
though rumors circulated that she'd been
pushed off a cliff
soon after williamson started calling
himself michelle dobrnovich
now in addition to claiming to be the
duke of sumatra
he also purported to be the heir to the
throne of serbia
and that wasn't the half of it
williamson
i mean dobrnovich joined a bogus
offshoot of the knights of malta
headquartered in shikshini pennsylvania
its ranks were filled with aging
fascists and
retired military and intelligence
officers
a few years later in the early 1970s
dobrnovich was consecrated as a bishop
in the obscure
american orthodox catholic church
an outfit with more links to intelligent
circles
and he relocated to santa barbara
california
there he founded his own religious order
called
the holy apostolic catholic church
and he briefly married a former b movie
actress
at the time i was a history graduate
student
at uc santa barbara and once met the
former
george hunt williamson i don't recall
much about the encounter
but the person who introduced us was a
retired
air force colonel of all things standing
back and looking at the strange career
of george hunt williamson i can't help
but suspect that he was a spy of some
sort
the only question is whose
[Music]
[Music]
you